people now trying to vote twice thank
you for joining us at four I'm Kirsten
Joyce and I'm Christian casalez well
it's an issue our eight news now
investigators have looked into for years
election security and now we're learning
just how many people attempted to vote
twice in the midterm election that
happened last month eight news now
investigator David charns here with that
answer David well we're talking about a
very small number of people who
attempted to vote twice of course those
attempts caught just showing our
elections are secure
what did we see in terms of fraud in
this election if any in every election
right there are anomalies there are
things that that warrant further
investigation uh in the the 2020
election psych 2022 election cycle
excuse me was was really no different in
that regard deputy secretary of state
Mark volusian says State investigators
have identified people who attempted to
vote twice in last month's election
those double votes did not make the
count with systems in place catching
them were there individuals in our state
who maybe made some bad decisions during
the 22 general election their word
appears there were volusion says one
example is voting by mail and then
attempting to vote in person or through
a provisional ballot but felashin won't
give the exact number of people his
office believes tried to cheat the
system we're talking small small numbers
to be clear though and I do want to
stress this you know one illegal
fraudulent vote is too many he points
out that secure priority measures in
place worked and measures the Nevada
legislature enacted two years ago
alongside the new mail-in voting law
scrubbed voter rolls of non-eligible and
deceased voters before during and after
an election there's a number of steps
that we take to ensure that every
eligible voter tests one vote the
individuals who are not eligible to vote
are not able to so far one person in
Nevada has faced voter fraud charges
connected to the 2020 election that case
alone taking a combined 240 hours to
investigate we're simply as thorough and
diligent as we possibly can be we want
the same thing you want we want our
elections to be secure now volition
wouldn't say the exact number of cases
that office is investigating he does say
that number would have no impact on the
results it's also important to point out
that those who said there was widespread
voter fraud in Nevada here in 2020 they
did not make the same claim in either
the June primary or in the election we
just had and they also lost several
court cases about those 2020 allegations
I'm David charns 8 News Now